the winner is Tony Earthman by mari nada
oh it was a very nice experience and
very interesting experience to stand
there for this for this little moment i
will definitely never forget that but
yeah what it looks for as it's special
because it's already like price when
you're nominated because your film is
subtitled and it goes out to so many
countries and that's like for a
filmmaker already a very big award I'm
Tony Tony Tony Edmund I'm consultant and
coach well I'm a political person but I
don't think that i do like political
films I hope that they raise some
questions later and in my film I feel
definitely tell something about the
globalised world we live in I think it's
always important to to leave something
open it was Tony at man it was really I
focused very much also on the on the
personal story of that characters it's
too messy fetish Mahmoud Abbas papa
haydn media mention we emphatically
tuppenny he selects again it started
with the wish to make a comedy or maybe
make a film about humor and while
shooting it became more and more
melancholic I had the feeling because
the thing is it's the father plays a
comedy for his daughter but he's doing
it out of desperation I have to arrest
you
yes must be done they have definitely
two very different systems of values the
father is for me is a very for me very
typical German character that belonged
to the post-war generation in Germany
that was very political and raised their
children with a lot of human values
hoping that something like the the
National Socialism us will never happen
again and so it's a bit hard for him to
see what she's doing now in a way he he
lost her to that globalised world that
he wants believe
[Music]